[Musik]
beim Fenster rausgeschaut und habe
gesehen dass draußen alles dunkel ist
nicht nur bei uns und August das
betrifft alle
zum Glück quasi unser Taschenlampen
liegt und habe es gleich gefunden
mit einem Blackout muss man immer
rechnen es ist immer eine Überraschung
und es kann jederzeit passieren aber wir
haben rechtzeitig begonnen uns darauf
vorzubereiten die
Kommunikationsleitungen funktionieren
auch wenn es keinen Strom gibt wir sind
nie ausgeschaltet unsere Aufgabe ist es
die Führungsfähigkeit der Republik im
Notfall zu unterstützen dabei arbeiten
wir direkt mit dem Bundeskanzleramt dem
Innenministerium und anderen staatlichen
Stellen zusammen
zum Glück sind wir gut vorbereitet gute
Vorbereitung ist in dem Fall alles
als erstes wollte man natürlich die
Informationen hören was ist passiert
zum Glück kann man das kurbelradio des
autark ist und so ist es unser Fenster
zu Außenwelt
bei einer Ausnahmesituation wie einen
Blackout stößt man sehr schnell an die
Grenzen seine personellen Ressourcen da
helfen wir als Soldaten aus vor allem
was Sicherheit und
infrastrukturproblemen aber natürlich
auch mit dem Einsatz von Spezialgerät
zum Beispiel mit einem Dieselgenerator
für eine lebenswichtige Einrichtung bei
der das Notstromaggregat ausgefallen ist
Lebensmittel für mindestens zwei Wochen
sollte man zu Hause haben vor allem lang
haltbare Lebensmittel
Preis Getreide Vollkornbrot Wasser nicht
vergessen
Trockenmilch zwei Wochen sollte man
schon zu Hause
[Musik]
die Aufrechterhaltung der Kommunikation
ist ein zentraler Punkt wir bekommen
laufend neue Meldungen die rasch
abgearbeitet und spezialisierten
Einheiten zugewiesen werden
wenn der Strom ausfällt ist sofort die
Versorgung mit Treibstoff und Wasser
unterbrochen
darauf sind wir vorbereitet und können
Polizei Feuerwehr und Rettung
einsatzfähig halten das macht mich schon
stolz
bei uns war schnell alles wieder normal
zur Abwechslung spielen wir auch mal für
mein ärgere dich nicht
[Applaus]
für so einen Ernstfall sind wir
ausgebildet worden nur dadurch können
wir solche unberechenbaren Situationen
gut meistern
Zeit für Fehler gibt es jetzt nicht
[Musik]
ohne Strom können wichtige Tiefkühllager
ausfallen in diesen Fällen kannst du zu
kommen dass gefährliche Stoffe austreten
bei solchen Einsätzen stehen wir den
Kameraden der Feuerwehr bei
[Musik]
einem Blackout fallen natürlich extrem
viele Versorgungseinrichtungen aus das
betrifft neben dem gesamten
Lebensmittelhandel Tankstellen und
Geschäften auch die Banken wir stehen
bereit mit größeren mannstärken rasch
die Polizei beim Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur zu unterstützen
[Musik]
und dann war wieder Licht